sur la place des parlements nationaux
alors encore une fois on en a pas parlé
dans le rapport mais on s'est mis assez
vite d'accord les 12 expert pour
reconnaître l'Union européenne comme un
système politique hybride qui est comme
tel et qu'il restera c'est-à-dire un
hybride la méthode communautaire
originale inventée dans les années 50
qui a subi une forme de
parlementarisation avec le Parlement
européen les élections européennes les
partis nationaux mais aussi un retour
des états avec le Conseil le Conseil
européen et les parlements et les
parlements nationaux c'est inscrit dans
les traités je pense qu'il y a une forme
d'équilibre là le défaut de ça c'est que
c'est compliqué à comprendre mais en
même temps c'est très efficace et et je
pense qu'il faut surtout pas toucher cet
équilibre et c'est un peu notre point de
vue parmi les rapporteurs de ne rien
proposer qui soit un changement radical
de la nature du système politique de
l'Union européenne qui qui doit rester à
l'articulation de ces trois approches
avec un rôle pour la commission la Cour
de justice un rôle pour le Parlement
européen un rôle pour les organes qui
représentent les États et de fait il y a
deux logiques de légitimation qui sont à
l'œuvre une qui est européenne via le
Parlement européen la Commission la cour
et une qui est nationale via le Conseil
le Conseil européen et les parlements
nationaux donc d'une certaine manière le
rôle des parlements nationaux n'est pas
éé évoqué dans notre rapport mais il est
en en quelque sorte présent entre les
lignes